hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to let's play Kraven Manor
Kraven man or I'm not sure but anyway so
this is a beta to a game that actually
is pretty interesting it's built on the
Unreal Engine like a Lucis but this one
is still in beta remind everyone but the
link is in the description below you can
check it out for yourself but it's got a
lot of work put in from what I've seen
and it was recommended by a couple other
let's players so anyway let's find out
what this is all about I'm guessing it
has to do with some sort of haunted
house of kinds I'm not exactly sure but
we will delve into the deep depths of
this divine and dastardly demonic
devilish Devlin's Isle I don't know
domicile that's the word I was gonna go
what did what did the heck is Devon
Scyld domicile I'm sorry my bad I'm an
idiot
alright so anyway as to walk backwards
Wow
really thanks heavy bronze ornaments
engraved with the letters K M I'm
guessing that means what is that is that
a goo goo goo goo goo ghost no it's a
spectral trail leading me to be
initially I lamented that the rituals of
October were failures however a month
later I turned my back to a statue I
thought hollow and dead and spirit
within made itself known does that even
mean I picked up a book I dropped a book
can I throw a book how do draw sorry
about the [ __ ] throw really kind of a
wimp anyway
well that's not good why did that happen
who's that what is that what is that
what is that what is that what is that
why Oh huh huh what are you are you what
are you what are you oh are you turning
towards me okay no it's like some sort
of mannequin statue hybrid is I don't
like it okay let's follow the spectral
trail because obviously I'm supposed to
go this way huh okay thank you
oh I have a flashlight okay well who's
there I have a flashlight better watch
out for me is this the heat does not
reach far into this cold room its warmth
would be comforting except this house is
supposed to be abandoned yet someone
some thing must have started the fire a
newspaper clipping describing a missing
teenager named Marjorie Hedgepeth
already then limbo is not truly a place
given time those within may move so to
our eyes they appear and disappear with
a horrible groan in the scent of burnt
and loss what I'm guessing you're
talking about ghosts there are rules or
poltergeists but anyway this is actually
looking really really impressive I mean
a lot of work is obviously being put
into this I can't quite go downstairs I
can't even jump for that matter but see
collected works for whosoever do not in
the truth boasting of phantasms brag
that they can do miracles be destined to
the torments of eternal fire interesting
I didn't quite understood understand
that rejecting the music of the spheres
as the movement of astronomical bodies
are incapable of generating sound
alrighty then lotta these seem to just
be sort of gibberish however to lift
drop or manipulate certain objects okay
wine cellar model
I'm sorry did I do that the hell was
that okay so there's a wine cellar model
here that I'm supposed to take with me
and I got some sorta I found a scale
model of the wine cellar it matches the
model I saw on the entryway I didn't see
a model in the entryway but I'm guessing
I need to take this back to the model I
don't know I don't know hello is someone
there
Oh
no thanks I don't want any ok the glass
all broke oh ha ha ok so I'm supposed to
put this in its place on the model list
here so rotate is that it nope that is
not it okay oh I need to oh I see I need
to attach it to this thing here but I
think that quite works oh I get it
red to red right that's what we're doing
instead no apparently we're not doing
that okay oh I heard that up on the
right so I am building the house really
does that mean oh it does mean whoa
oh I'm tired I was sprinting Oh like
what was that no way this is so cool
that is like the coolest thing I've ever
seen well not really but I'm trying to
be excited about this I built the wine
cellar
into the upstairs room how crazy is that
I don't like this place but that was
pretty cool Oh notice to all cravin
Metal Works employees season layabout
shall be disciplined by lord craven
craven and shall receive no wages during
recuperation
hi something tore into this painting
leaving claw marks in the frame well
that's not good there are many good
things that I know about that is not one
of them within these construction
expense reports are references to hidden
past wages passageways and moving walls
no kidding
alright then get out of my way please
I said plays this photo is labeled 1857
Craven metal Woodson depicts a grim
well-dressed man in his 40s at the grand
opening of the factory the blueprint
design is attributed to woven craving
scrupulous detail and extremely strange
structural components what is that that
a spoon I can't pick that up ok nothing
else here seriously yes there's
atmosphere and the unique mechanics and
and the the unique approach to the game
is really really good what was that what
was that it was orange what was that I
don't know what that was
hmm why am I going towards it I don't
know my gamer instinct is telling me to
move forward but my wimpy baby instinct
is telling me to run away look at trails
of blood not good sign
okay I agree with that sentiment I will
follow its instructions I am going to
get out why do they have to be
mannequins
oh I can't get out lever is that there
before I don't want anything oh good
I found the bedroom this is gonna be
phenomenal oh look another way out okay
I'm leaving now thank you goodbye
forever
okay was it was it was mr. dick oh oh
man oh man oh man okay all right stop
being wimpy baby man
I'm wondering what the going on over
here
I guess that's when the game is finished
cuz remember this is just the beta of
the game wait did I put that there oh I
put I put that on top of where it was
before but I guess it's noon ah I see
you see you I see you you son of a [ __ ]
I'm gonna close that door on you
oh you closed it on yourself yeah yeah
you can't mess with none of this I'm too
amazing for you Dan I don't know why I
don't know why I don't like mannequins
but they're like worse than monsters
diagrams and sketches of human teeth are
good that's comforting
I just Oh God hello are you Lord Craven
all right nice paintings where is he
cuz I know he's here and he's gonna pop
out a news article describing the
visible decrease of homeless and ending
in indigent in doubtful Pass West
Virginia police chief takes credit for
cleaning up the town okie-dokie wire
globe feels almost like it has a slight
electric charge a bunch of little
mannequin douches ones red why is one
red and that's probably the active one
good great though fathers beatings war
Mira hated mothers ceaseless lying most
seeing them die was an epiphany there is
beauty and death I've never forgotten
William Craven is a crazy son of a [ __ ]
what is this
George Craven 408 Oh to this
black-and-white photo depicts a male
body on his knees leaning over with its
head submerged in a vat of molten bronze
how creative at least I can find some
good in every situation there cuz that
sure is a creative way to kill someone
knows that yeah no thank you I don't
want to go to hell in a way oh no oh no
oh no what's in here what's in here a
pile of dark blurry photos depicting
about six men and women nude but
decorative streaks of red they're
dancing around a glass orb and setting
appears to be on top of a floor of a
library I gotta go back to the library I
don't want to go back to the library oh
no I see you what are you gonna do Oh
what are you gonna do what are you gonna
do what are you gonna do what are you
gonna do what are you gonna do what are
you gonna do where are you yeah we're
too good
the shadow was there and now how do I
destroy you son of a [ __ ] what is that
big thing in the corner what is that
thing bull corn what did that do what
did that do bull chain go go go go go go
go close
that was a son of a [ __ ] oh man I did
not like that the nature of limbo has
revealed itself to me it is the
receptacle in the state of existence
were in the spirit can be contained oh
you mean like in a mannequin my earliest
successes were briefed but invigorating
after the ritual Maleficarum the large
orbs held the spirits for seconds at a
time and glowed visibly oh not the
library I was just at the library
carefully detailed illustration of a
human arm being dipped in bronze with
all
[Music]
that's why he oranges he's and we're
just brownies dyed dipped in bronze
that's not good oh there's the door
again good good good good good good good
good good good good good good not good
but you know alright good I guess I
don't know I see where this is going
oh maybe not all right then I'll put it
there okay
still this is like the coolest thing
I've ever seen in my life that was awful
how is terrifying I hated every second
of that oh man oh that's me again how's
it look
what now what now just what next what
more can you do to me
the monster is waiting in the shadows
you know was here moving between the
walls it mocks my brethren not my
present I worked hard picking out those
present a false book the false book a
false book okey-dokey
okay so I got to put him in an order Wow
I'm a genius look at me I can't move
wrong I'm gonna do it again what you
mark yes
you're a son of a [ __ ] you're like a
mixture of a lot of moms that I don't
like your son of a [ __ ] your son of a
[ __ ] you're a son of a [ __ ] stop
crawling on the ground that's weird this
guy and then the last one ah good hell
yes I'm the Wiener
I got a token with the engraved letters
of KM yes my air just kicked odd so
something was like on the back of my
deck kind of like oh man I like it but I
hate it really you know I like games it
are you Deacon actually scare me what is
that what is that what is that what now
what could you possibly do more where
does this go oh do I gotta take it to
that where where does that light tell me
I need to go what is you what are you oh
I see okay done got it nailed it all
right all right was it weird books on
necromancy elements in alchemy okay
that's not good
well hello what what okay thank you
you're doing it for me apparently Oh
righty then this is actually a pretty
considerable beta I'm very impressed I
must somehow get to this white room I
can manipulate the other rooms on the
table to create a path but the pieces
only seem to fit in a very specific
order huh all right then so I need to
get to that room so I need to there must
be another room in the library that I
overlooked so because there's still a
white light telling me to go there
so I'm assuming that there's something
in there
seriously guys you guys what the hell oh
it's locked
whoa what the heck they're all locked
down why are they all locked and we're
locked before were they empty pedestal
um let me try this room now I haven't
gone down this way yet but here's
something scratched at this wall with
their fingernails until they
well that's not good um see photograph
shows an elaborate scale model the grand
manner with many runs in tiny fridge er
furniture the aged hands of an older man
appear in the image making adjustments
to the model okay all right so that must
be Lord Craven in his older years you
know I haven't even stopped to think
about how I got here and you know what I
didn't even care I didn't care how I got
here as soon as I walked through the
door I was so immersed in the game that
I I didn't even care about anything
other than what was happening right in
front of me in that that is so cool okay
I am back into this I got a I got a move
these two okay
I think hey you can do that right no
apparently you cannot I see a path that
I can create here but maybe I gotta put
those there until I can move I see a way
for that aha there we go okay so then
the next one is this which I rotate
tah-dah and then kaboom sweet oh that
room does not look good at the end I
just looked at that
it's like pillars and filled with blood
how is that good how is that in any way
a good thing why isn't telling me to go
up there now I don't think that I think
a door leads anywhere doesn't know it's
locked
what are you doing your spectral ghost
douche I need to go through the stairs
at the bottom anyway ah little thing
doesn't know what he's talking about
hey lights don't dick with me now I
think that the thing is dead okay I
think that it's dead you can let it stay
dead alright okay I gotta go through the
library again alright found another I
must okay I already know that I just
need to get to the back of this through
that door over there
hmm what now what could you possibly do
what the jack and wearing purple is tell
you shut up the green is a liar this the
globe belongs in the third frame to the
left
okay greens a liar blue is honest
okay so green is definitely a liar blue
is telling the truth so that eliminates
white green and blue okay red says third
frame from the left that would be blue
frame belongs on the leftmost side to be
yellow okay purple is selling the truth
and says the frame belongs in the
leftmost side so that means either
yellow or blue gets the or but I don't
oh I see
third from the left no okay so it must
go here right ah ah what is that third
frame from the left you're wrong you're
a liar that's what you are oh man
liar which one are you pointing to maybe
they're all liars
well not only one of the inscriptions
tell the truth I think okay so it's not
the rightmost frame that's definitely
it's not that one and it's not the
leftmost frame so ergo the red said it
would be the third frames from the left
so oh come on who's who you okay you in
red okay so White's a liar okay so blue
is dishonest that means green is telling
the truth so it's yeah Green was right
all along
all those never mind I'm just
go away go I see lever oh good oh good
oh good oh great
Oh Fantasmic oh oh not the wine cellar
okay what what was that what is that
what is that what is that what is that
what is that what is that oh you just
blew through those obstacles for me well
thank you thank you friend
whatever you are already let's follow
you what's this one in the world
okay there's bottles of wine I write
this entry with trembling bleeding hands
the trap was sprung as I place the globe
in the frame I must have done something
wrong I'm sure it's close okay that's
okay no no okay
I just need to look at okay so the order
of the Far tone seemed to be away hang
on say that again
I didn't
[Music]
don't boo
wait why oh no no oh no oh no oh no okay
don't do a medium low high medium get in
there how do I throw you know know how
to got stop dropping just don't hand I'm
tone-deaf just let me get up there okay
okay so this one first
this might be the deep one yeah yeah
then I think I couldn't tell if this one
was the high one damn it okay that was
not it okay then my simple process of
elimination I've almost got this I got a
hurry though I got a hurry
oh crap was this it I think this was a
low one yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah come on
come on I'm dying here I'm dying I can't
die now get in there get in there get in
there come on let me up there there we
go okay Bing bong winner winner chicken
dinner
get me out of here get me out of here
thank you my god
I couldn't hear like which one was which
and I couldn't get close to it okay I
carefully explained to each on that this
is not death they will still live more
fully than before yet they wail and call
me a monster they fail to appreciate
their contribution okay all right doing
good doing good see those types of
puzzles are pretty cool and you got like
a time limit so you're like rush press
to rush to it anyway all right let's see
what we got here oh it doesn't look good
the order no I wrote a note but
apparently nothing got written down what
is this whoa what the hell Oh what the
hell
whoa whoa oh okay I'm getting blocked
off there's another globe which was used
to trap Souls an orb can hold a soul for
seconds the statues for years when the
ritual is held on kravid manor itself
limbo may mean life everlasting oh so
the whole manner itself probably has the
soul of lord craven craven craven
probably craven hello oh hi hey there
buddy
how you doing you know I got a safe for
a beta
I would never picture this as a beta
this is a full game to me this game is
amazing and it was free with our sticky
bones and thin skin the saw and the
hammer have taught me come on what what
where to go wait where to go where to go
oh oh wait there it is um our earthly
bodies are death destined to rot okay
that was it that was not worth trying to
get so um what am i doing about this
what's going on here where am I going
what am i doing as a mannequin arm see
handbook of physiology cutting blade
it's a blade or dull and bent from use
good to know anything here that I need
nope but there's chains on the ceiling
whoa hello ah oh no you run where do i
rod
run run away where do I run get off of
me get off of me get off of me get off
of me oh my god you run faster in run
man run run run you stupid douche ok ok
ok gotta gotta gotta gotta gotta I'm
here I'm here what do i do what do i do
what do i do what do I know what do i do
what do i do what do i do what do i do
there's nothing here
there's nothing in the walls do i what
do i do what do i do what do i do what
did i do
oh the monster spirits truck oh okay I
got to get out of here um was there a
way up over here or is this not where
I'm supposed to go probably not I got to
get out of here this whole place is
coming down okay yeah I gotta go I gotta
go I gotta get out of here we're out of
here we're out here Bros oh not that gas
that whole things on fire now
everything's on fire oh this is not good
wait hang on I gotta go the other way
get out I'm taking your advice like
right now I'm taking your advice I'll
crap a crap lever lever lever lever
lever lever come on come on come on got
a sense of urgency sense of urgency
pull it
what are you doing oh I see two levers
pull them both why won't you pull damn
it whole damn it that one won't pull oh
there's a series of oh there's three
levers and Oh what is there another
lever somewhere
all right opened okay it opened um god
damn you can't put a puzzle pressure on
me like that I'm getting out of here
yeah you don't need oh crap oh now you
got me get off of me here strike this
orb come here [ __ ] come here
AHA suck on that
kaboom oh now everything here is on fire
oh that's not good
that's not good gosh nike's where am I
now people laugh we go get out okay
oh how how do I get out how do I get out
oh I see all this that's that's not good
this isn't normal
what is going on here is that is that is
the house helping me get out whoa whoa
now oh come on how do I get up that oh
man what is going on here this is so
crazy this is insane I got to get some
how I got to get on top of this and then
I can there we go okay there we go got
it got it got it got it nailed it
nailing it nailing it nail it oh my god
this is insane this is amazing I wish I
could stop and appreciate the scenery
that was amazing I'm out of here I'm
outta here
I shouldn't have come in this place in
the first place I am out of here
so it seems if the boy remains locked o
powered by something but you stop
hitting me I didn't even know you were
there how do I go I get it
hang on I got to get him to destroy
something what has he got to destroy
though just painting maybe no maybe he's
got to destroy the door probably hit
come on ma hit it hit it good oh I see
there's an orb floating up there why
didn't I see that before I'm an idiot I
gotta get him to hit the chandelier or
but hold on where to go there it is come
on hit me
ow [ __ ] I don't know how I'm gonna get
the timing right MA
damn it did it get it
no aw it's so close
it's so close come on hit it hit it hit
it I'm up it's right there damn it
hit it hit it come on come on hit it
this is never gonna happen and it's
gonna kill me before it gets to it
okay I think I got a pop out from hiding
like to time it right now if you shoot
it yes yes yes yes give me first give me
the room oh no no no no no no open up
open up
where'd it go where'd it go is there
another one what's going on what's going
on what's going on what's going on I
don't know tell me tell me your secrets
turn it edit there's got to be something
else up here unless it's supposed to hit
the door maybe that's my only guest
okay no no no to hitting the door I got
to get out of here
something something what oh it's right
here duh duh hit me where did this one
come from how did I miss that let's
freaking walking through here Wow Wow
come on run man you need to run
hit it hit it no don't go over it hit it
there we go let me up yes yes yes
[Music]
haha suck on that [ __ ]
ow my head why you do that Oh Oh No
that's not a good thing this is not good
this right here not good guy yeah that's
not good that's not good
[Music]
hi Wow
that was absolutely incredible
everything about that was amazing that
was one of the best horror games I've
ever played in my life that was
incredible
it was so good everything about that was
amazing
I can't even begin to describe how
awesome that was you guys you guys saw
it till you know that was amazing I
can't even begin I mean it's it's better
because it's sure in its very contained
but and it's totally free far as I know
I got it for free someone sent me a
downloading copies a bit that was
incredible
I am blown away by that that was
absolutely who did that where the
credits roll credits man man that was
amazing I can't recommend that more I
mean when that what when that man
manikin first started coming at me I was
I was scared like I've never been scared
before my life and then everything was
cool and then the whole place was
exploding and the mechanics were kind of
you know hard to get it first but as
soon as he got me like Oh dah uh of
course
and it was like oh man it was so
incredible whoever did this I would have
paid money for this I would have gladly
paid you know ten fifteen bucks for this
I was incredible even though it was like
a thirty minute game
[Music]
best horror game ever her man that was
great that was incredible there were
that many aw man look at all the hooker
[Music]
all right I'm gonna let the credits roll
because oh they're quoting all the
paintings and who painted them so
obviously they didn't make the paintings
the paintings are masterpieces from all
around time and so anyway so anyway I
was absolutely incredible I couldn't
recommend this game more try it for
yourself maybe there's something in I
miss remember this game is still only in
beta so there could be a lot more I
thought it was just gonna be like one
room you go into but it was the whole
freaking game I think man that was
amazing oh man
everyone should play that game and
support the developers that was
absolutely incredible
so anyway I'm done raving so oh man
great game so thank you all so much for
watching click the annotation for more
videos since I've done and as always I
will see you in the next video
[Music]